¿Cómo podríamos medir el poder de un país? Es decir, su capacidad de imponer su voluntad
sobre otros países. Podríamos empezar por
su Producto Interior Bruto, su Renta per Cápita
o… el tamaño de su ejército. Pero yo tengo
otra idea. La mejor forma de demostrar tu
poder es obligando a otro país igual de grande
que el tuyo a hacer un auténtico sacrificio.
Algo que va en contra de su voluntad pero
que… van a terminar haciendo sólo porque
tú quieres.
Pues bien, eso es lo que va a probar Donald
Trump con la Unión Europea ¿Y cuál es ese
sacrificio que quiere imponer Trump a los
europeos? Muy sencillo: cortar sus relaciones
con la República islámica de Irán. Pero
¿De verdad hablamos de un sacrificio tan
grande? Y lo que es más importante… ¿Hasta
qué puede imponer su voluntad Donald Trump?
En este vídeo, te lo vamos a contar.
Irán es un país famoso por varias cosas:
las alfombras persas, los programas de enriquecimiento
de uranio y… los automóviles. Sí, amigos
de VisualPolitik, Irán es uno de los mayores
fabricantes de coches de todo Oriente Medio.
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando… ¿Irán?
¡Pero si es un país en vías de desarrollo!
¡Pero si están prácticamente aislados!
Pues no sólo fabrican coches ¡Es que además
tienen sus propias marcas! Por ejemplo, este
coche que veis aquí es el KHODRO SAMAND,
un sedan que se vende muy bien, no sólo en
Irán sino también en Azerbaijan, Rusia y…
¡Venezuela! Vale, no os esperéis ninguna
maravilla… por lo que dicen las revistas
especializadas, sus motores son obsoletos
y los acabados dejan mucho que desear. Pero
tiene un precio imbatible: 7000 dólares.
De hecho, no sólo se vende en Irán sino
también en otros países como Rusia, Azerbaiján
o incluso Venezuela ¿Os imagináis lo que
pasaría si le pusiéramos unas pocas mejoras?
Un sedan de este tipo, con un precio tan tentador,
podría venderse en muchos otros países.
Y eso explica que, a partir del año 2015,
cuando se levantaron las sanciones a Irán,
muchísimas empresas europeas se lanzaran
a invertir en el país.
Renault entrará en una joint venture en Irán
Peugeot-Citroen vuelven a Irán para hacer
un acuerdo para fabricar coches
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de coches! Veréis,
la Bolsa de Teherán tiene una capitalización
3 veces más grande que, por ejemplo, la de
Egipto. Y tienen todo tipo de empresas. A
diferencia de otros países de la zona, que
están dominados por el petróleo, Irán tiene
una economía muy diversificada: bancos, minería
y hasta telecomunicaciones. Y eso también
ha atraído a otro tipo de empresas europeas.
Vodafone entra en Irán mediante una asociación
con HiWEB
Por si todo esto fuera poco, Irán tiene una
población muy bien educada. La tasa de alfabetización
es mucho más alta que en Siria, Iraq o muchos
de los países vecinos. Más de 4 millones
de ciudadanos estudian o han estudiado en
la Universidad. Y eso significa mano de obra
cualificada y dispuesta a trabajar por sueldos
relativamente bajos. Si a esto le sumamos
que el país tiene más de 80 millones de
habitantes y que está todo por hacer, tenemos
que la República Islámica de Irán es todo
un destino para invertir. Sin embargo, toda
esta oleada de dinero europeo se acaba de
frenar en seco.
Trump dice que Estados Unidos sancionara a
las empresas Europeas que hagan negocios con
Irán
¡Pero esperad un momento! Vamos a ver…
Donald Trump es el presidente de… Estados
Unidos. Podrá imponer sanciones a las empresas
de SU país pero… ¿Europa? ¿Qué puede
hacer en Europa? ¿Cómo puede legislar sobre
las empresas de otros países donde, al menos
en teoría, no tiene poder? ¿Por qué le
iban a hacer caso? ¿Es esto una bravuconeada
de Trump…? ¿O tal vez no? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
EL DUELO LEGISLATIVO
En marzo de 2018, ZTE, que es una empresa
de teléfonos móviles china tuvo que pagar
una multa de unos 1000 millones de dólares
a Estados Unidos ¿Su delito? Importar microchips
de Estados Unidos y venderlos en Irán. La
Casa Blanca les dijo “¡Ah! ¿Qué hacéis
negocios con los malos? Pues elegid… o me
pagáis una multa millonario o tenéis prohibido
vender cosas en mi país” ¿Dejar de vender
en Estados Unidos? ¿El mercado más rico
del mundo? ¡ZTE está dispuesta a pagar una
multa y no volver a pisar Irán en el resto
de su existencia! Y lo mismo está pasando
con muchas empresas.
Pero como ya hemos dicho, las empresas europeas
se han lanzado a hacer negocios con Irán.
No sólo hablamos de compra de petróleo sino
de inversiones de todo tipo. Así que, tan
pronto como Trump aprobó las nuevas sanciones
contra Irán, la Unión Europea le plantó
cara.
Europa exige excepciones a las sanciones de
Trump para la energía, aviación y más
Básicamente, los líderes europeos escribieron
una carta a la Casa Blanca pidiéndole que
respetara sus intereses económicos. Como
sabéis, Trump no es precisamente muy amigo
de la Unión Europea. Así que, ya os podéis
imaginar su respuesta.
Así que el 7 de agosto de 2018, la Unión
Europea pasó a la acción. Se acabaron las
cartas, y todo lo demás. Había llegado el
momento de activar la REGULACIÓN 2271/96.
Ah! ¿Qué no
sabéis lo que es la regulación 2271/96?
Pues no pasa nada, para estoy yo ¡Para explicaros
lo que es
la regulación 2271/96. Pues algo así como
un escudo legal anti guerras comerciales.
Vamos a poner un ejemplo. Imaginad que RENAULT
tiene una fábrica en suelo iraní. CHEVROLET,
que es una empresa estadunidense, se entera
y les denuncia. Estados Unidos impone una
multa a RENAULT. Pues bien, automáticamente,
la Unión Europea impondría una multa equivalente
a CHEVROLET por daños y perjuicios ¡Pero
no sólo eso! Si CITROEN dijera “uff, yo
no quiero problemas… me marcho de Irán”,
la Unión Europea TAMBIÉN le pondría una
multa. Porque cualquier empresa europea que
obedezca las sanciones impuestas por Washington
está incumpliendo la ley europea.
En otras palabras, que todas esas empresas
que estaban haciendo negocios con Irán lo
están pasando mal. Si se quedan en el país
de los Ayatolás… golpe de remo de Washington.
Si se marchan, golpe de remo de Bruselas.
Se trata de todo un duelo político ¿Quién
tiene más poder? ¿Qué golpe de remo prefieren
las empresas europeas? Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver.
LA CRUDA REALIDAD
Seguro que todos vosotros habréis hecho alguna
vez una transferencia internacional. Por ejemplo,
vivís en Colombia y hacéis un trabajo para
una empresa Australiana. Cuando hacéis la
factura, no ponéis vuestra cuenta de banco
normal ¿verdad? En su lugar, ponéis un número
muy largo y unas letras raras. Algo así como
esto.
Pues bien, esas letras raras son el llamado
Código SWIFT. El sistema SWIFT sirve para
hacer transacciones internacionales. Se trata
de una red que conecta a casi todos los bancos
del mundo. Y durante décadas, Irán estaba
aislada de esta red. Es decir, que aunque
alguien quisiera hacer negocios con Irán…
¡No podía! Porque ¿Cómo vas a hacer negocios
con alguien si no le puedes mandar dinero?
La única opción sería mandar un maletín
con billetes, y es un poco incómodo.
En el año 2015, cuando se aprobó el acuerdo
nuclear, Irán volvió a entrar en el sistema
SWIFT. Y ese fue el auténtico momento en
el que Irán pudo hacer negocios con el extranjero.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién controla este
sistema SWIFT? Pues, efectivamente, una empresa
que se llama SWIFT ¿Y a que no adivináis
dónde tiene la sede? ¡Exacto! En Bélgica
¡Eso está en Europa!
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Si todas
las transacciones internacionales se gestionan
desde Europa… Estados Unidos va a tener
que tragarse sus palabras en este duelo político
¿Verdad? Pues… os equivocáis.
Veréis, SWIFT es una sociedad cooperativa.
Las decisiones se toman en un consejo de administración
compuesto por 25 representantes de bancos
de todo el mundo.
Y resulta que en ese consejo de administración
hay dos estadounidenses. Uno de CITY BANK
y otra de J.P. MORGAN. Y muy probablemente,
estos dos representantes tendrían que pagar
multas millonarias si no consiguen convencer
a sus compañeros de que SWIFT desconecte
a Irán de toda la red.
Si esto llegara a ocurrir, a efectos prácticos,
Irán volvería a estar aislado del mercado
internacional. Si no puedes hacer transacciones,
no puedes hacer negocios. Así de simple.
Se trata de algo tan importante, que la Unión
Europea ya está intentando sacar un sistema
alternativo para hacer transferencias internacionales.
Algo así como una versión moderna del TRUEQUE
de toda la vida.
Lo llaman SPV o Vehículo para Propósitos
Especiales. La idea es que, en lugar de cambiar
bienes por dinero, Europa quiere pagar con
créditos sobre otros bienes. Por ejemplo,
imaginad que REPSOL, que es una empresa española,
le quiere comprar un cargamento de petróleo
a Irán. Pues bien, en lugar de pagarle en
dinero, podría pagar con una máquina que
valga lo mismo que los barriles que van a
comprar.
¿Puede funcionar algo así? Sólo el tiempo
lo dirá. Pero… vamos a suponer que sí.
Que las empresas empiezan a usar este sistema
SPV para comerciar con Irán.
Volvamos al ejemplo de REPSOL. Ese zumo de
dinosaurio que ha comprado tendrá que llegar
de alguna forma ¿Verdad? Alguien tendrá
que transportarlo en un barco petrolero hasta
el puerto de Barcelona, por ejemplo.
Pues bien, la mayor parte de los buques petroleros
del mundo los controla una empresa que se
llama MAERSK.¡Eso también está en Europa!
¡Pero cuidado porque no todo es tan fácil!
Para que ese barco de MAERS.
¡MaesK!
¡MAERSKKK!
¡Para que ese barco danés pueda descargar
su mercancía en Barcelona tiene que estar
asegurado! Ningún puerto del mundo aceptaría
un barco petrolero sino está asegurado. Y
resulta que casi todas compañías de seguros
que trabajan con petróleo son estadounidenses…
o tienen muchos intereses en Estados Unidos.
Y eso explica noticias como esta.
El gigante del transporte maritimo, MAERSK,
abandonará Irán por las amenazas de sanciones
En otros países como China ya han encontrado
otras alternativas. Tienen sus propias empresas
de seguros y sus propias empresas de transporte.
Además, por la cuenta que les trae, les interesa
mantener el contacto con Irán como sea. Es
el sexto proveedor de petróleo más importante
que tienen. El 7% de las importaciones de
zumo de dinosaurio en China vienen de Teherán.
En el caso de Europa, las importaciones de
Irán son mucho más pequeñas. Es decir,
Irán es importante, que sí, que todo lo
que tu quieras… pero no es el recopetín…
En otras palabras, que si Europa quisiera
seguir comprando zumo de dinosaurio a Irán
tendría que buscar nuevas empresas de transporte,
nuevas empresas de seguros y, además, comprarlo
a través del…
trueque.
A ver… en esta vida, todo es posible. Pero,
a estas alturas de la película, parece que
Estados Unidos y Donald Trump le están ganando
el pulso a la Unión Europea. Y todo esto
tiene varias consecuencias. En este otro vídeo
os contábamos lo que está ocurriendo con
el mercado internacional del petróleo. Y
en las próximas semanas hablaremos de las
posibles consecuencias que puede tener para
el régimen de los Ayatolás en Irán.
Mientras tanto la pregunta es ¿Pueden estas
sanciones acabar con el régimen de Irán?
¿Hasta dónde pueden subir los precios del
petróleo? Podéis dejarme vuestras teorías
en los comentarios y en los siguientes vídeos,
veremos si coinciden con las nuestras.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que publicamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik ¡Y dadle a la
campanita para que os lleguen todas nuestras
actualizaciones! Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.